hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Anna I'm not gonna turn
around cuz [ __ ] that
you know why okay anyway someone told me
that I need to put the plant food which
makes totes
looking masks which makes totes sense
what hey
I can't wait the reticle went away for a
second and yeah I can pull it down now
Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] you go oh look at me oh yeah no oh
yeah
no damn debt a hacky hack huh oh it is
there's still some ha missing to live in
her up alive in her up I don't wanna do
that
ooh oh ooh ah ah I'm friggin by 2d
sprite
I live in her up who bought something
going crazy and this guy's head I'm
going real crazy alright this will make
for I think there's like five or six all
the corners of the room or something
oh there's one up in the sky route got
yeah give me huh you want some over
there see you you can see yourself here
and now Wow huh huh ooh ooh ooh ooh ooh
there's like lights right
there's an eyeball there's an eyeball
what what oh okay that's that's cool and
all what uh hell water was that more
symbols face you still looking at me
like what's that Oh why's that boned
something missing there lying her up if
you know what I mean
good boy ooh boy this this is what's
going on chair help please please please
okay all right that wasn't theirs
there's nothing oh oh oh I gotta clean
it off
use the black whale to clean up good
good burn it off no dice no dice guys
you guys I don't know shut up what are
you what are you thinking I know what
I'm doing it getting it off oh yeah I
don't know clear idea okay anyway so I
got all the routes supposed to do
something with them I I forget as
mentioned in the comments but I
Oh God damn you oh you look so stupid
and ugly and able to move it
therapy I'm not talking about the chair
today oh it does
oh no oh boy
whoo doggy that's dead no good
huh I heard something
I heard tap tappy someone tapping on the
other end of the mirror maybe maybe
maybe
okay all right
it was like I use this dicks that's rich
can't use it
I've already pulled okay let me
oh oh and what's happened to the outside
world didn't you say at the beginning of
this you were in like some sort of
nightmare what happened in my box what
happened in my box
Oh No No
the note is gone is definitely not open
a bull that thing is not there's nothing
down there okay
ashes of the heart oh I'll just get some
I'll just get some cuz why not
they're viscous to the touch I suppose
like burn these no dice Lu what tells
that light gun its hands in hands my
hands almost looks like flame
ooh an outline of some dude behind me my
hands my hands yeah stop touching my
feet uh-uh Oh No Oh No
okay there's five hands and they're not
usable though so there's nothing to it
just some on the floor
why why'd you make me do these things
why you why you hate me so I do you all
hate me so much
wait a minute oh wait ah that was it
okay uh-huh
and now I just put one in ah I thought I
said I couldn't use it before but in
that one okay yeah put it that way you
know best guy you're the crazy one one
this was where the new painting land the
one I stabbed
[Music]
okay okay that it that it's gone it's
gone oh oh oh oh no no no no no what is
that
I took it in the wall okay
all right a weird image hmm that's fun
anybody will jump out at me
okay now what
Oh do I burn them oh hang on
[ __ ] that's it okay oh it doesn't
burn douse it with death how about a
knife what do I have them it's so up
come on it's so appropriate there we go
oh there's the face it does not look
like a flame anymore he does not he does
not could go through and do this to each
for one I talk about a time-waster I got
all the time in the world I don't care
that I could ever not bothered at all ah
what would happen in those chairs why
does that happen
who did this Oh
[Music]
oh come on oh shut up shut up God shut
up if it's the mask upstairs all its
dubbed
everything's creaking what about a
handsome friggin mother who why do I
still this freak frackie mask on why why
why why
Meno lucky will not like it but me brave
be brave big one the mask fell off
that's what happened there you'll be
ashamed to put it right back on a what
was the point of that is that only to
get the mask off oh oh hang on John
relief of a visit
it looks like the mask there we go
can't do it yourself to cover it Oh with
the veil oh ok ok bleak just say the
least
can't use it why not Oh what what's with
the hands top five freaking yes freaky
ok
ooh that one's on oh yeah hey buddy
it almost looks like a flame really
really just almost ablaze drew he stuck
to the wall but this one seems very very
on fire he's docked to the wall whoo
I got a wooden base soon but what does
that do for me and why did that fire out
okay all right chairs still stacked up
stoves still there I took out my ashes
and she said kill all living things
don't make me go back up don't make me
go back up I don't wanna I don't wanna
oh wait maybe I gotta cut them now let's
try this okay probably not
it's almost empty I wouldn't doubt it
okay so I can't cut them so that means
oh don't know I don't ha ha it's our
time that's it that's it that's it oh
sorry all eyes there huh okay thank you
all so much for watching now as always
I'll see you in the next part
bye bye